i'm the king of sketch design what do
you think that paper crown makes you the
king of sketch design
the crown doesn't make me king the
checklist
on the back of the crown makes me king
what's going on guys my name is david
thomach and welcome back to the channel
probably don't need the crown on for
this video let's put that away
today we're talking about sketch design
and what you need to do
to be able to produce a good set of
sketch design documents
i know a few of you been asking so take
some notes and let's get started so
there are a number of things that you
need to follow
in a sketch design set of documents
however there's only really
three main sheets that you need to
produce the cover page is obvious i'm
not even going to talk about the cover
page
but you need to include one a site plan
to the floor plan or floor plans
depending on how many levels it is
and three elevations the purpose of the
site plan at sketch design stage is to
indicate
the location of the design against the
property
it is very important that you get some
sort of feature survey
that will be able to tell you the levels
and the contours of that block
because that is absolutely crucial if
you go and design for a flat block
and then all of a sudden you find out
that block is sloping
five meters every single meter you're in
big trouble
so the first key element is obviously
get a feature survey a couple basic
points to get out the way
is you need a north point and a scale
bar on the site plan
you also need your title block with all
the details filled in
when we look at the actual drawing you
need to showcase the feature survey
which shows the boundaries and all the
levels on it you need to showcase the
external walls
only of the property we don't need to
see any internals just yet
so external walls only you want to be
able to showcase all the plumbing
features as well
that means sinks toilets showers baths
etc whatever you can think of that's
plumbing related
make sure you show it on the site plan
stairs and ramps are also an important
factor
that you show on sketch design for the
site plan it's something that's
transitioned all the way through towards
the end
but it's good practice to keep at the
very beginning the rest of the site then
indicates the landscaping the driveway
the pathways
and anything that might be of critical
importance if you have a very large tree
in the middle
it might be good to note that you might
need to remove that tree or design
around it
finally the one thing that you want to
showcase is your area calculations how
big
is the ground floor living how big is
the garage how big is the storeroom
how big is the alfresco these are the
things that people need to know
especially if you're going to a build up
very early on they can quickly look at
these numbers
put some of their own numbers together
and spit out a very generic rough price
now if you aren't taking notes that's
okay this checklist is available to
download on my website
so if you look down in the description
below you'll find a link to this
checklist to download
today and because it is a 28 day
challenge i will be giving away
10 of these checklists to you guys to be
a winner all you have to do is subscribe
to this channel and
follow me on instagram leave your
instagram handle in the comments below
and i will pick a winner at the end of
february the site plan in general
should be at a minimum of 1 to 200 scale
you want it to be this size because it
doesn't need to showcase
detailed information but it needs to
showcase the whole site
moving on to the site plan the site plan
gets a little bit bigger
it goes to one to 100 scale because you
want to showcase
everything inside that building
depending on the size of the design
if one to 100 doesn't fit on a3 you're
going to have to move up to a2
a1 or a0 once you hit the a0 stage if it
still doesn't fit at 1 to 100
then it's up to you to decide if you
want to shrink it down
or if you want to split it across
multiple pages similar to the site plan
you want to showcase your north point
your title bar and of course your scale
bar
on the floor plan itself we continue to
show just the boundary lines of the
property
not the rest of the feature survey
information we also show
all the external walls and the plumbing
the stairs everything we showcased on
the site plan
but also start to include the more
detailed items like the internal walls
all the internal doors
all the openings all the doors all the
windows the floor plan is about showing
size scale and moveability so it's
important that you start showcasing
some numbers straight away you want to
be able to understand how big a room is
and what that room is
so make sure you title it for example
bedroom one and underneath
you have the size of that room for
example four meters by four meters
something to take note of is furniture
isn't critical but furniture is a good
indicator for clients who don't know
about scale drawings
to be able to understand space if you
put a bed
inside a bedroom and you can see a
decent amount of space next to it
the client's immediately going to know
that yep okay i have plenty of space in
that room
alternatively if you show that bed in a
room that's too small
then obviously the client is going to be
able to pick up and go hmm that room
seems a little bit too small for me i'd
like to be able to add a chair for
example
so again furniture not critical but it's
definitely something that adds to the
experience you also want to showcase all
four elevation markers of the entire
property so if there's four sides you're
obviously going to show four
if there's more than four sides and you
need to showcase more well then it's up
to you and your discretion
to make more elevation markers if need
be if you're designing a two story three
story or more
it's also important to showcase the roof
on the floor below
now finally the elevations are again one
to one hundred
and they are a lot more diagrammatic at
this point in time
the purpose of the elevations is to
showcase the architectural
interpretation and expression
it's to understand what the architect is
thinking and to convey that to the
client
so it is predominantly about materiality
and scale like all your other pages the
title block remains on that page
however the north point and the scale
bar can be removed
because now you're showing four
elevations more than likely on one page
the orientation of the north point is
very different so it's no longer
required
it's important that we start showing a
little bit more detail in relation to
the site here
so we want to be able to showcase the
natural ground level which is
interpreted
from the feature survey information and
the future ground level
if you are altering that site in any way
shape or form so for example if it is a
cliff and you want to bank into it build
a retaining wall
it's important that you show one that
retaining wall and two
that new ground level that is eventually
going to form that level of the house
we predominantly focus here on the
external walls the windows the doors and
the roof
you want to be able to showcase all of
these elements but at the same time
show a materiality legend or some sort
of key to indicate
what each material is some people do it
by actually noting each individual item
at sketch design other people
note it with a legend by cropping out a
tiny piece of the building
moving it across and saying this is
glass window for example
how you do it is completely up to you
but one thing that you do have to
remember
is again that scale proportion so we
want to indicate
story heights and story levels so if you
start at the ground floor you move up
for example to the ceiling of the ground
floor which is
two seven it can be 2.7 meters above
natural ground level and then you might
have your next floor which is three one
and then your next floor which is
another two seven above it so it'd be
plus five eight
i think you get my point if you don't
i'm happy to explain further in the
comments down below just let me know
and that's all you really need to know
for sketch design guys it's three very
basic pages with some basic information
that gets the architectural idea across
the line anyway that's all for me today
guys thanks so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below
and because it is february i will see
you tomorrow